uh we're going to go next to
just to keep it going in the united
states i do want to let our american
friends get in on here let's go to tyler
from austin texas
the new home of joe rogan tyler what is
it like having joe rogan in town
you know i hear a lot of complaints
about it but it doesn't really bother me
it is what it is you know very people
want to come here and contribute to the
economy
and i'm fine with it cool we'll move out
yet
what's on your mind so my question
is about something i've been doing a
little bit of investigating into
is the opinions that a lot of
conservative media pundits have held
about trump in the past back in the 2016
election
right they said extremely disparaging
things about him
uh and they were in full recognition
that he was a racist
even like an anti-semite so on and so
forth
and what i'm really concerned about is
following
this election even if trump loses what
is gonna stop
um when are conservatives gonna reflect
and realize that the candidate has gone
too far
that even though he has the effect that
they want on their base
ginning up support that he is too out of
left field that he's too awful of a
person
when are they gonna have a moment of
reflection because i don't see that
happening right now i don't see
them realizing the situation that
they've gotten themselves into
well there is a lot of cognitive
dissonance that prevents people from
having that awakening and so
i think that only if donald trump
brutally loses i'm talking about
landslide loss and
republicans lose the senate i mean if
there's a real repudiation of everything
republicans are and stand for at the
senate and white house level
will you see some republicans say that
was
really disastrous that can never happen
again but otherwise
i think you'll see even if trump loses a
lot of republicans chalk it up to
coronavirus
a lot of republicans chalk it up to bad
timing and i i would be shocked if
there's any kind of serious so
self-examination a reckoning of sorts
yeah
i doubt it i just don't think you're
gonna see it um because i'm worried
about somebody who's just as bad
as trump or even worse in the future
coming along
and being legitimized just like he has
and i can't see a reason why they
wouldn't do that since he has been a
really
reliable vehicle like i said and like
you've said before for ginning up that
support
and like rachel bittikoffer said for
activating his base
you're completely right you're
completely right if they go against him
then they cancel out that section of the
electorate and they have to figure out a
way to move
left which i can't see them doing that
no i think that in fact
um it it it would take some very
accurate politicking for several
election cycles to get past the risk
that very soon
a trump number two comes forward and
whether it's one of his kids or whether
it's someone else
yeah i don't know but we're gonna have
to work really hard to prevent that and
and step removing
trump with and replacing him with biden
is just the first step of many
i've seen norman orensey and i don't
know if you know who that is the
political scientist he says that the
republicans need to lose three elections
in a row
in a landslide in order for them to have
this reckoning that we're talking about
that's my instinct
i think i think that he's right yeah
okay well thank you so much for the call
it kind of really caught me off guard
that i just got slid into the room i
appreciate it tyler tyler from austin
texas great to hear from you
uh we are going to go next to um
where are we going next let's go to our
friend
sasha from montreal one of my favorite
favorite
uh cities in the world i would even say
sasha from montreal you can uh go ahead
and yeah let me know what's on your mind
today
well i was kind of disappointed
yesterday to be fair
yeah um
only i was really disappointed like
just the interruption but finally
couldn't speak
he couldn't talk he couldn't it was
crazy yeah
i just i shouldn't have watched it like
i was just
i was really hyped for it but sorry you
were hyped or you were high
hyped all right i know some people who
were both but
yeah no i understand i mean are you do
you imagine you'll watch the next
debates
i mean probably you will okay nothing
better to do i guess
yeah all right anything else for me
sasha
um not really no
uh you ever go to st via tour bagel in
montreal
uh i don't think so oh i recommend it
i don't actually live there i live in
the the suburbs oh you're in the suburbs
yeah all right sasha very good i
appreciate the phone call
okay all right there it is sasha from
montreal very good
understated phone call